it's been a different type of
performance for johnny depp six weeks in
a virginia courtroom and seven jury
members won over
his name has been cleared he says the
decision that he had been defamed by his
former wife amber heard but her lawyers
say she will appeal the verdict
you know one of the first things she
said is i am so sorry to all those women
out there this is a setback for all
women in and outside the courtroom and
she feels and she feels the burden of
that
beneath the celebrity circus this trial
has addressed serious issues allegations
of physical emotional and sexual
violence
domestic abuse survivors say the
reaction to amber heard has carried
undertones of misogyny a vilification
they say which could deter victims from
reporting domestic abuse i would say
that
some victims probably will be
reserved in coming forward and saying
anything when i first heard of what was
this what what was on full display with
social media and the backlashes that she
was receiving and how she was unbelieved
it took me back to where i once was
where she was
and uh there were some trigger points
there the court's decision may have gone
dep's way but the portrait of him played
out of drug abuse heavy drinking and
violent rouse cast doubt on his ability
to return to hollywood's a-list in
showbiz you know they have to analyze to
what extent there will be a backlash
if they test johnny regardless of what
the jury decided yesterday and i
you know if the women who don't want
this to be the end of the metoo movement
are about to pounce on the first
producers who consider starring death in
a major movie
amber heard say she can't afford to pay
johnny depp the more than 10 million
dollars in damages their own personal
legal battle continues its ramifications
extend far beyond this virginia
courthouse martha kellner sky news
virginia